ce alors que tous cas ce que croit d'eau
ahmed et ibrahim font partie de l'équipe
des médiateurs sociaux de la verrière
ce soir là ils sont dans le quartier du
bois de l'étang pour parler avec les
jeunes présents dehors objectif faire de
la médiation
à aucun moment on est là pour remplacer
la police ou quoi que ce soit on a juste
pour donner un message
même si on essaye dans le quartier on
peut réussir dans la vie facile des fois
dans la vie c'est pas facile mais voilà
on peut toujours s'en sortir avec les
bonnes personnes et on peut être
toujours bon conseiller
même si des fois dans des familles ça
peut pas le faire où chaque personne
comme des jeunes sont mal orientés donc
nous on est là personne pour les aider
et les orienter orly-parc le bois de
l'étang le village les médiateurs
sociaux se rendent dans les différents
quartiers de la commune depuis le 18
décembre 2020 une équipe de huit
personnes soir six médiateurs vacataires
employé par la mairie et deux agents de
proximité co financé principalement par
l'état
parmi eux fab en bas makalou ce qu'on
fait au départ c'est convoquons tard on
va on fait connaissance avec les jeunes
c'est surtout ça qui est important au
départ on essaie de savoir ce qu'ils
font dans la vie parce qu'il ya
plusieurs personnes qui sont descendues
quartier pour les plannings à deux
adultes relais de la préfecture qui
travaillent du lundi au vendredi pour
les vacataires
eux ils font du vendredi samedi dimanche
et sont amenés aussi à travailler les
jours fériés
cette idée des médiateurs sociaux une
proposition de nicolas dainville durant
la campagne des municipales de 2020 une
dimension sociale être à l'écouté des
jeunes instaurer un dialogue essaie de
les orienter au mieux dans leurs
activités leur recherche d'emploi
et puis une dimension tranquillité
publique pour rappeler les règles
comportement de respect du voisinage
pour que tout se passe bien dans nos
quartiers la municipalité actuellement
en discussions avec les bailleurs
sociaux présents sur la commune
objectif construire des partenariats
avec eux autour de la médiation sociale